it's good to see you again because i
interviewed you on zoom when the
documentary first came out
the i would call it to say the least
game-changing documentary for this case
at this point
uh you've got your whole crew here today
what brought the crew here
for this hearing um you know britney
spears is supposed to speak at this
hearing
uh you know a lot of people have been
saying it's the first time she'll be
speaking but we actually know from an
investigation we published yesterday
that it's not we know that
brittany has been expressing her
discontent extreme discontent with the
conservatorship for many years
these sealed court documents really
showed us that she's been asking
and that she's been asking for her dad
to be removed for years
and so it's all been behind closed doors
so possibly
we'll see if if she actually is you know
if the public is able to
hear what she says but uh she might we
might be able to hear her say that
actually
you know i mean i read that article and
another game changer um
because that had been kind of this
laurel that
you know some of the narrative had been
resting on right well brittany could ask
anytime
to get out of this but she hasn't so
what was your reaction when you first
saw those documents
um i mean i it was it was pure evidence
i was really shocked
that the narrative would be put out
there so much you know
her father's lawyer vivian thorin has
been saying
britney has never petitioned to end it
and i think she's using lawyerly
semantics because
we know her britney's court-appointed
attorney who she didn't choose
would would file the petition at her
request but we have
seen in these documents very explicitly
that she has asked him to communicate to
that
that to the court as early as 2014 we
didn't see any documents before 2014 but
now it's seven years later
he hasn't done that and you know what he
also has not even filed a petition for
her
father to be removed even though the
judge gave him that uh
you know opportunity in november and now
it's june
what does that say to you as someone
who's been working on this so closely
you know all the players in this game
what does that say to you about the
lawyers here brittany's lawyer
especially
i mean i think we really have to look
really hard at this conservatorship
system and the conflict of interest
in a you know a person not being able to
choose their own lawyer
being represented by someone uh you know
chosen by the court who is making money
as long as she's in the conservatorship
that's a huge conflict of interest in
the system that we're exposing because
we think it's in the public interest
so you get these documents i have to ask
how did you get these documents this
came out a day before her hearing
and these were leaked court documents to
you essentially yep we're really good
journalists we're a really good
investigative reporters
your crew being here what does that mean
is there a follow-up documentary coming
you know we wanted to capture it just uh
in case we're not
totally sure yet but we ended the
documentary
on a scene outside the courthouse like
this where the
judge declined to suspend her father
an immediate suspension and that was
kind of the the note it ended on so
we would we thought we could if we do
another one we could
pick back up here on the time where
she's supposed to speak and see if
that's different
and last question for you i remember you
told me that felicia was someone you
were still in contact with from
brittany's team i believe
who do you think like there was some
criticism of her boyfriend in the press
and
and who do you think is on britney's
side here knowing what you know who do
you see as her
champions that are rooting for her and
do have her best interest at heart
i don't know
you